[Music]
well
ryan i suppose um
we should start with the ads right yeah
definitely
wait why are you laughing
this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because
i mean that was pretty good i mean
it wasn't florida good but it was sorry
i'm sorry we were in florida last night
and they were just uh they just dislike
advertisements more than you it's fine
i tell you what shawn delete that we'll
just go back and do it we'll pretend
that didn't happen and we'll start from
the beginning all right here we go
all right take one
[Laughter]
this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because
i really want to apologize and there's
like three or four people who are in
advertising in here and i
look i know
you're a part of the problem but um
but it doesn't mean we don't love you
any i mean we do it's just that um there
is a major major issue going on right
now it's called consumerism and it's
fueled by markers marketers and
demographers and so forth and i was used
to be one of these people so i i totally
get it anyway we have a special guest
here tonight before we get there i guess
we give them an introduction my name is
joshua fields milburn and i'm ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists and we are live here in
atlanta
oh man we have a special guest for you
here tonight um here's how these things
work we'll have a short conversation but
then there's a microphone set up back
here as well so if any of you have a
question and you want to go over to the
microphone it usually takes one person
to break the seal and then all of a
sudden there is a herd of people who run
toward the microphone and so that first
courageous person can break the seal
we'll take it easy on you i promise
but before
we get to questions ryan i thought we
would bring up our guest
what a special night it is tonight and
i'm grateful that we get to spend this
evening with you and and with him you
know him from netflix you know him from
the minimalist podcast and you also know
him from his hit show revolution of one
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
stage tk coleman
[Applause]
so you all wrote the book but i wrote
the theme song
i love people
use things
coming album is coming out this is
christmas
there's an ep that uh yeah i got i got a
funny story about uh music you wanna
hear it yeah one here has nothing to do
with anything that we're here for
tonight but
so i've been traveling a lot this past
month you guys know know this being on
tour in and out of uber rides hotels and
so on so i live in charleston it's not
like la where you can always get an uber
so you got to schedule ahead of time
so it's like 4 30 in the morning i'm
standing outside it's dark out there i'm
waiting on my uber ride just me my
lonesome my briefcase
and
driver pulls up and his windows are
tinted and uh you just hear the sound of
his base like
now usually what happens is i walk up to
my car
the driver gets out they reach for my
suitcase i go no no i'm good and then
they say no no i got it i go no no i'm
good they say i got it and i said okay
cool thank you right and then they take
my my suitcase this guy didn't do that
you just see the pop the trunk pop
so it's 4 30 in the morning it's dark
outside i'm by myself
trunk pops i'm like okay all right so i
put my own you know suitcase in and then
i get in he says nothing to me he just
looks at me through the rear view keeps
going with this music still loud doesn't
turn it down at all
so we get like halfway to the airport
and we're stopped at a red light and he
turns his music down no no first before
he turns it on he says something
something i go what
some something i say what
something something what
then he turns his music down and he says
it's my music too loud
okay it's not over right
so
as you all know big part of my
philosophy of life is to strive for a
life of self-authenticity to be willing
to stand alone for the sake of taking
the stand
and you know you got to be willing to
look people in the eyes and speak your
truth even if that means they might be
disappointed in you or they might
stereotype you and so i'm thinking to
myself i want to tell this guy the truth
right now
but we're like 10 minutes away from the
airport and if i tell him the truth it
might be an awkward ride right and if he
stereotypes me in the wrong direction i
might get like a with like two stars or
something like that i want those five
stars
all right so there's truth or five-star
rating
you know priorities got to keep that
rating yeah yeah so that sounds like a
memoir title
by tk coleman truth or five stars i love
it
actually sounds like a self-help book
five-star truth
so i'm sitting there and i'm like man
and he's he's waiting on his answer and
this red light is lasting forever right
and i'm thinking okay this this inner
voice says
you cannot tell students
that they need to be authentic
and refuse to tell this man what you
really think
and i'm like oh man
i just got to keep it real
and uh he's looking at me his hands are
on the volume dog
the light is red i'm waiting for it to
turn green
is my music too loud
and i say hey man i'm
i'm just gonna keep it real with you bro
to be honest i love mariah carey so you
can turn that all the way up
all the way up bro
and the whole way there man we just like
dream lover come on
we were working it man for the whole 10
minutes that was the best ride
nothing to do with anything that we're
here for but that's my traveling story
god tk i love you yeah man
oh that's great tk's been on our podcast
i think nine times at this point he's at
this point the honorary third minimalist
and um what basketball player does that
remind you of
jeff hornacek
[Laughter]
no one gets the reference it's fine
it's a 90s basketball reference
but tonight
is special because
you and i and ryan it's almost as though
like
we we have this weird venn diagram of
things that we disagree about and ryan
and i disagree about things all the time
but when we put this third puzzle piece
in here it's almost as though like tk
becomes the mediator and we form some
sort of daytime
and it feels like even we're disagreeing
we're agreeing about everything i don't
know how you do it man there's a little
bit of magic so we got a microphone back
there i'd love to uh
to start answering some questions hi uh
my name is alejandra i'm gonna read it
so it's easier for me great um
yeah so i have one question and then one
request for the audience but it's
something nice
since uh since i started listening to
you guys i live in three different
countries but your message hit me
different when i arrived here to do my
phd
i've seen how overconsumption is seen as
an
intrinsic part of being a person in the
united states because uh we don't use
the term american like you guys do
um
so even when i say i don't have a car in
atlanta people see that as a superpower
of being
someone from abroad so my question is if
you've seen that over consumption is
used as a part of being an american and
also in a critique way are you seeing
that minimalism is being shown as a
western solution because i feel that
sometimes
and depends what do you mean by western
exactly
i think sometimes
is like a problem that other countries
have not created and i think the power
of or sorry depression of under
consuming is being put in places where
we're not producing this program sure
what's the problem specifically oh over
consumption having too many things i
feel uh
even for some immigrant communities here
that's a way to defend because we have
to pretend to be
from here right
in in the book we talk about let's just
take human beings out of it for a second
there's this great study
between
about chimps and bonobos
and um what we learn is that as babies
chimps and bonobos are essentially the
same they'll share their bananas with
other chimps and bonobos that are around
them but as they get older they tend to
bifurcate and the bonobos will share in
fact they'll even share when you try to
force them to not share
and you incentivize them to not share
they become even more generous
the chimpanzees if they if you give them
two if you give them one banana they'll
eat it if you give them enough to eat
for themselves and then enough to share
they will share but if you give them an
over abundance of bananas they will
fight other chimpanzees to the death to
hold on to those bananas which will then
just rot after they've killed the other
chimpanzees
and so
what's the uh the moral of this is we
get to decide where we end up here i
don't even think it's a uniquely western
problem or a uniquely human problem
necessarily it could be a primate
problem or it could be
amplified though by
the western world by americans in fact
it's funny when we tour overseas
people still call it the american dream
in australia they call it the american
dream in canada they call it the
american dream in south africa they call
it the american dream
and what is it it used to be what was
the american dream before oh if i make a
modest salary i could buy a modest house
and earn modest meads to provide for my
family right that sounds wonderful but
now it's
not keeping up with the joneses it's
keeping up with everyone on your
instagram feed and so it's been
exacerbated by the western world for
sure but i think there's a fundamental
problem there as well
what do you think tka
so i think
part of what separates us as human
beings from
inanimate objects or plant life is that
we crave action
we're not just brains in a vat we're not
just lifeless statuettes we like to move
around we like to do stuff and not just
do stuff we like to do stuff that is
meaningful we crave purposefully
directed action we we long to use our
organs and our faculties to express
ourselves creatively in a way that
uniquely showcases our like preferences
our priorities and so on
and so
we're not truly fulfilled unless we are
creative i heard someone say once that
if aliens were to come visit our planet
and they were to look at our science
they wouldn't be really impressed
because their scientific understanding
of the
universe would be superior to ours if
they looked at our technology they
really wouldn't be impressed because
their technology would be presumably
more advanced than ours but if they went
into our comedy clubs into our theaters
if they watch the way that we compose
songs when we fall in love they would
say wow
what's that that's really interesting
because art is subjective that what
makes us human is our capacity to create
that's where we find our deepest
gladness now what happens when we become
alienated from our creative self
well
we tend to become consumers
not just consumers in a way that's
necessary to sustain life in a healthy
manner but consumers in a way of trying
to compensate for a void in our lives
that can only be fulfilled through that
expression of our highest self and there
are many ways to be out of touch with
your creativity you can be out of touch
with creativity because you have low
self-esteem you can be out of touch with
creativity because you believe other
people are better than you because you
don't believe that it's possible because
you feel like you don't have money and
so when you look around the world in
different geographical spaces you find
human beings come up with different
excuses or different reasons in
different places at different times
throughout history
for not believing in their creativity
the solution is the same but the
manifestation of the problem varies from
individual to individual and so what i
would say is what's unique about america
is that the reason we use
for alienating ourselves from creativity
is consumption that's what makes us
unique but what binds us all together as
a species is that
we love to create and ultimately
minimalism is just a way of getting back
to that right so i wouldn't think about
minimalism mathematically as if it's a
philosophy that's characterized by the
absence of stuff but i would say
minimalism you want to think about it
meaningfully it's it's characterized by
the presence of
purposeful creative action and that's
the solution and it works for anyone
anywhere but we have to figure out
what's their unique cultural hang up
that's separating them from that first
does that make sense yeah yeah i really
should have went before you
tk know the alien talk reminds me of the
we've had some good talks about aliens
like
i'm not like but i don't believe in
aliens but i love talking about all that
all that alien stuff anyway i i got that
example came from um i almost hate to
admit this but coast to coast a.m
that's where they talked about me
credibility
you know i really appreciate the
critique because you know i really
i try to live the most genuine life
possible like that is the one thing i've
learned
over the last 10 years is like that's
that's
unbeknowingly to me that's how you
really get to like love the person you
see in the mirror it's like when you
live a genuine life
it's so much easier to look at yourself
in the mirror and it's easy to take
critiques because honestly like anything
should be able to be critiqued
and when it comes to minimalism
i i love having these conversations
because i do think from that perspective
of consumption
that maybe it is just a western solution
a western problem
but kind of as tk was illuminating you
know minimalism it's an answer to a lot
of different problems
and and i think it like you said these
problems they manifest in different ways
but you know i've had people email me
from kenya
who are like hey like i just want to say
thank you so much for your message
because you know i'm in kenya and i was
trying to get this job at the bank
because i wanted to consume and what i
realized
is that the life i have is actually a
really good life and there's no reason
to like throw myself into this this job
just to be able to consume like an
american
and so it doesn't
minimalism yes it helps with the stuff
it helps with if you're if you're a
hoarder
but it also helps like if you're a
collector and like maybe you want to
like uh you know minimize some of your
collection or you're an artist and you
got too many art supplies but also it
helps with the impulse and that is
really what i appreciate about
minimalism is like no matter where you
are in the world there is this impulse
we all have to consume as much as
possible and what minimalism helps us do
is it stops that impulse and helps us
question it and sometimes we act on it
that's okay but if we act on it every
single time like that's where the misery
starts to seep in so you know is
minimalism a western solution yeah but
it's also an eastern solution solution
for anyone
they might just have a different problem
that they're using minimalism to solve
yeah i think all the great thinkers that
i'm
that i'm inspired by not all of them but
many of them are are from the eastern
world from india in particular
and
i mean they're ancient philosophies
and so this is not a new
solution i don't think of it as a
solution but i understand why people use
that word it's not a new idea but what
is new is the problem and it's this
western problem that has been amplified
by i mean it doesn't feel a bit
dystopian that the place you buy
groceries from is also the place that
you know is essentially where you buy
everything from i mean this was what
movies did as almost a parody of the
future just 20 30 years ago it was like
oh yeah everything you buy is all going
to come from one mega corporation they'd
call it like acme or something and it
turns out it's just amazon now
and now people when people hear me say
that they think i'm saying well amazon
is bad or evil and we should
do something to them no no i'm not
talking about that what i'm talking
about is how we make our decisions and
what we do quite often is we opt for
convenience we remove all of our
friction and that sounds wonderful until
you realize once you've removed all the
friction you also lose traction if
you're just driving on ice you're going
to slide all over the place and that's
what we're doing right now with
consumerism thanks for your question
thanks uh i don't want to get that
request passed is um your book in the
georgia library system has always like a
30 people waiting line because there's
only like one copy in the whole state so
if anyone here has a spare copy please
donate it
yes yes please uh that's awesome that's
how you can minimize it afterwards man
there's a bunch of minimalists going to
the library wait wait in 30 in line
that's crazy yeah it's
and the thing is i know they try to
supply a bunch to libraries but at some
point like the best way we can do that
is when you're done with the book you
just donate it to your local library
it'll go right into the system
beautiful thank you so much yeah thanks
for the request
howdy hey patreon supporter here what's
your name oh man samia hey samir thanks
for supporting us what's on your mind
um you kind of answered this but i was
looking for a little bit deeper answer
um it's rare that you you see a duo like
you guys worked together for so long um
how do you resolve conflict
you know
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
is there any context that you wanna no
no context no context i just give in as
much as i can honestly
let's talk about what what what do you
mean by conflict really because
um and i'm not trying to put you guys in
this no i'm not it's a good question
i'll talk about whatever you want to
talk about i'm just trying to i just i
don't
the question presupposes that there's
conflict
no though so so for example like if you
know i've had businesses in the past
where i've had partners some of them
worked out well some of them didn't work
out well and i'm thinking how could i
have better
uh headed off that conflict rather than
saying this isn't going to work and
throw my hands up in the air and walk
away
yeah i mean for me
in a situation like that like with a
business partner i am in a situation
like that with a business party
well i mean first off josh and i have
known each other since we were fat
little fifth graders that's totally true
so like we know each other very very
well which means we really understand
each other's preferences we understand
each other's likes and dislikes and and
our little quirks and whatever it is and
the fact is is that him and i or even me
and tk i mean you know these are two men
that i really really love so i go out of
my way
to respect their preferences to respect
them and here's a here's so that's
number one is i go out of my way to
respect my friends family business
partners the other thing because that is
the best way to get respect back by the
way is when you can go out of your way
to respect someone's preferences then
they're more apt to go out of their way
to respect your preferences if you're
starting from a zero-sum game and you're
like well i'm not going to budge until
they budge i mean that's
probably not not the right approach
but uh the other the other thing too
is oh man i totally forgot what it was
i got an answer but it's a short one i'd
love to hear what tk has to say about
conflict
okay go now okay
[Laughter]
well you know i think about this uh
bobby mcferrin song don't worry be happy
and don't worry that's not my answer but
there's a line in there where he says uh
in every life you have some trouble but
when you worry you make it devil
yeah yeah we could
i love that line though because
it captures the idea that having
problems isn't a problem what makes
problems difficult is we resent our
lives for even having them
and so i think the first step to dealing
with any problem is embracing the
process of problem solving as a
spiritual practice to recognize that
problems are not curses but problems are
gifts not because they feel good but
because they make us better and most of
the things in life that are for our good
are the things that challenge us are the
things that push us out of our comfort
zones because we not only attract things
into our lives based on our current
state of consciousness but also based on
our own innate impulse towards progress
there's a part of us that's in tune with
certain realities but there's another
part of us that's always striving to
become a better version of ourselves and
sometimes we attract people and
challenges into our lives that are
designed to help us get to that next
level of self-authenticity so when you
have a problem say you know what
i'm going to
be present in a state of non-judgmental
open-mindedness and attend to what this
problem is trying to teach me
second because you didn't just ask about
problems you asked about conflict which
presupposes that there's another person
involved i just read a quote the other
day by mother angelica that said being a
saint would be easy if it wasn't for
other people
that's the hard part right so when you
put the other person in there it gets
really difficult here's one piece of
advice i'd give on that and i'll hand it
over to josh i would say
whenever you're trying to resolve a
problem with another person
don't try to convince the other person
that or
don't don't base your solution on trying
to get the other person to agree with
you on how much of an idiot you think
they're being
because if the other person needs to
agree with you on how much of an idiot
you think they're being in order to
solve the problem the problem will never
get solved
instead of focusing on their idiocy
step back and focus on what is the goal
because what is a problem
a problem is when you have a goal some
kind of outcome experience or result you
want to create and then there's some
other kind of thing that functions as an
obstacle standing between you and that
desired outcome that's what the problem
is and problems cannot exist if we
didn't have goals or outcomes that we
want to create and so use that problem
as an opportunity to take inventory of
the outcomes you want to create and say
is there an opportunity for me to let
that go
is there an opportunity for me to let go
of the assumption that i need that
outcome in order to be who i am that i
need that outcome in order to be happy
and also you can ask yourself
is there a way of going about that
outcome
that doesn't require me to be married to
the path
that i've become addicted to following
so can i let go of either the outcome or
can i let go of my one-dimensional way
of thinking about how to manifest that
outcome
i love that man it's like
it's like are you
are you is it are you willing to let it
go are you willing to like plant your
flag and die on this hill
and so and thanks because like that
totally helped me grab my thought back
from the ether
[Laughter]
i don't take things personal like i try
so hard to not take things personal to
say i don't take things personal that's
like 99 true there are some times where
i catch myself in that and i'm like wait
why am i taking this so personal like
this is a problem that a friend has
and i have the opportunity to help them
solve it this isn't a knock at me
this is this is just an inconvenience
right now or yeah maybe it is a problem
arising so not take and i do this with
my my wife mariah who's here somewhere
thanks for coming mariah
yeah
i i try really hard like to just not
take things personal because sometimes
you know sometimes i'll be in a mood
myself
for whatever reason
and i might have a certain
energy that i'm projecting or an emotion
that i'm projecting
and it has nothing to do with anyone but
me
and it's like i will have to sometimes
say like hey i know i'm being kind of a
crap head right now i see kid in the
front audience so i'm going to try and
not cut this whole podcast
you know i'm tr i know i'm like being a
jerk right now but please don't take
this personal it's it truly is not you
it's me i'm just like a little messed up
right now so not only do i not take
things personal i also try to go out of
my way to like make sure other people
aren't taking things personal from me
what's your name man
samir sameer
all conflict is self-conflict
i think that
we get so caught up in thinking that um
the problem is outside of us
and then whatever the other person's
behavior is is making us mad
but the anger arises within us and that
person could behave in that same exact
situation or quote unquote worse with
someone else with a completely different
outcome the anger would not arise within
them so anytime we feel frustrated
anytime we feel upset
any time we feel offended
and we get offended recreationally now
that's never someone else's problem it's
always my even if they've done something
to intentionally try to to offend me
to upset me
it's up to me
and so
the reason that we often get offended is
because we've been we've been told a lie
that things are good or bad or right or
wrong the other day ryan and i were
talking about this very specific thing
and he told me i was being complacent
about that thing
and
a knee-jerk reaction for me would be
like well no i'm not but the answer is
yeah i am and what's wrong with that i i
felt like was yes it is perfectly
appropriate for me to be complacent
about this thing and so yes you're right
i understand that i am
and
because ryan wasn't saying well you
should be another way and i think the
way the reason we have very little
conflict between us is because we love
each other but
most of us don't understand what love is
we say love is what
there's a bit in the book where it's um
i love my wife but i also love burritos
well neither one of those things are
love when we talk about it because when
we talk about loving burritos what does
that mean i really like this thing
that's great
well when i say i love my wife what does
that mean well most of us say i mean it
means it it's an attachment i'm attached
to this person
i need you we've been told those lies by
pop songs for a long time now right
i need you in order to be happy
you complete me
nonsense
i'm already complete without you but you
do augment or enhance my experience of
life to love someone
is to see them for who they are without
trying to change them and so the reason
ryan and i don't have a ton of con
conflict is because
i'm not trying to change him
and he's not trying to change me to try
to change someone
means you hate who they are
you can tweet that podcast sean
yeah
yeah you had me at hello man oh man
especially when you were like cause you
were looking at me you were like you you
don't i'm completing myself but you walk
me at me t.k you incomplete me that's
right but we love you still
man you know it made me think when
you're saying that josh how
whenever there is some type of
disagreement or misunderstanding or you
can call the conflict wherever you want
i look at it as an opportunity to like
understand you more yeah and through
understanding you i understand
other people
and so
when you escalate a conflict you are
losing that opportunity to have a deeper
understanding for who whatever it is
whoever it is that you're having that
conflict with
so going out of your way to understand
is always going to it's just always
going to be more meaningful well the
opposite of that is what
self-righteousness
and so that's the reason that we want to
be right in a situation in order for me
to be right someone else has to be wrong
these are just cultural imperatives that
we've made up oh i'm right there for
you're wrong it's like maybe we just
have a different understanding of this
thing help me understand your
understanding and even at the end of
this if i don't completely understand it
doesn't mean that i'm right
it just means that i don't understand
you know one thing i'll add to that is
we've kind of been conditioned to think
about power as something that depends on
getting other people to see reality in
the same way as you and so if if i can't
convince you
to
believe in my idea or if i can't
convince you to vote in the way that i
vote well then i'm fundamentally
powerless because all power is
democratic right
certainly there's no such thing as the
creative power of the individual which
can be expressed in a way
that's independent of other people's
disagreement well
most of the good things that we get in
life comes from that kind of creative
power there's this beautiful moment and
um i'm going old school here but it's in
one of the matrix movies where uh
morpheus he's this very esoteric
character who believes in a lot of
strange things and he's arguing with
this very pragmatic man and telling him
what he thinks the solution is and he
gets very upset and he says damn it
morpheus not everyone believes in in in
fairies and oracles and all of these
things not everyone believes as you
believe and morpheus looked at him and
he said fortunately my beliefs do not
require them to
power isn't the ability to out debate
people power isn't the ability to use
argument or logic to make people feel
pressured to see things the way that you
do power is the ability to look another
person in the eye and say
you don't see it the way that i do
that's okay i give you permission to be
who you need to be because i know how to
express myself authentically and
creatively in spite of your disagreement
i love you anyway and i'm gonna do me
anyway and our lives will intersect
organically at the place where our
deepest gladness meets that's power amen
all right y'all real quick for right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalist
it's a brand new year 2022 and we're
actually taking this week off that's why
we shared with you the first section of
our love people use things event in
atlanta if you'd like to watch the rest
of that event as well as all 20 of our
love people use things tour stops head
on over to patreon.com
the minimalist you also gain access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
previous live events future live events
special ask the minimalist anything
sessions and so much more of less that's
patreon.com
the minimalists you can follow the
minimalists on tick tock instagram
facebook and twitter at the minimalists
if you want our podcast show notes in
your inbox sign up for our email list
over at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus podcast sean alabama jordan no
more social jess danny unknown emma the
immigrant and the rest of our team i'm
joshua fields milburn
reminding you to love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it
you